Thank you, see?
All right, take care.
Let's see.
Let's check in with our caller from Country
Code 44, country code 44.
Who is this?
Where are you calling from?
Oh, yeah, that's you.
Oh, yeah.
I'm I'm a student in Edinburgh now, just stuck
in the middle of a project.
But I just want to call in.
I'm a first time caller.
I I've really been interested in American
politics for so long now.
To be honest with you, I used to look down
on people that didn't partake in elections
myself.
But with all that's happened in this Democratic
primary and stuff, I the people I look down
on now is the people that actually bother
to take part in these these elections.
You know, I've never understood why people
didn't vote.
But now I do.
You know, Bernie Sanders, what the DNC did
to him in terms of the way they organize themselves,
you know, to reorient around Biden the way
all the candidates just dropped out of the
organized nature of of this was really just
got to me.
And, you know, I just don't understand how
people can look at Biden and think, you know.
Yeah.
I mean, there's no doubt that Biden is better
than Trump.
No,
nobody's doubting that for one second.
But.
Well, what happens after, you know, a Biden
presidency?
You know, are we just going to assume that
Biden is a setup to, you know, a better future
for America?
To be honest with you, the way American history
suggests right after Biden, there's just going
to be another tempest.
You know, I don't get it.
I mean, I don't agree.
I don't I don't believe that that's at all
a guarantee.
I think about it.
I think about it this way.
Imagine, you know, a large cruise ship and
you have one place you want it to go.
And Republicans have a different place that
that they wanted to go.
For me, the perfect analogy, which is an incrementalist
analogy rather than an acceleration, is the
analogy is the earlier you turn towards your
destination, the less erratic your future
turns need to be.
And we've all seen these examples of, you
know, of a small change in the angle at which
you leave Boston could get you to Scotland
or it could get you to Morocco.
And so my view is not one where every election
needs to be assessed as what is the setup
for the subsequent election?
And what is it likely to lead to?
What I
know is another four years of Trump steering
the ship gets us much further than where four
years of Biden gets us.
In either case, at the end of the next four
years, we're not going to be where we want
to be, but we will be closer with Joe Biden.
And for me, it's that simple.
So I think we just have a fundamental disagreements
of the principle here.
Yeah, but I look at, you know, the Obama campaign,
for instance, you know, I'm.
Hickey run as a as a puppy based, basically
a populist.
In 2008, for all intents and purposes, you
know, it's especially when you juxtapose him
against somebody like, you know, Clinton.
And I agree.
So I agree that, you know, here you had Clinton.
Obama ran on a populist ish sort of campaign.
But really, Obama, I think, ran on a, you
know, sort of pragmatic center left, you know,
more open to progressive ideas than someone
like Clinton.
But I don't know that I would primarily characterize
Obama's campaign as populist.
Yes.
But, you know, well, I'm well, I'm trying
to say is when you look at the last three
elections.
Yeah.
And you look at, you know that the people
of the people that lost the last three elections,
you know, John McCain, Mitt Romney, Clinton,
you know, these are establishment candidates.
You know, these are people that, you know,
have a vote, have made a name for themselves
in politics for such a long time before they
decide to run.
And you look at Obama and Trump, you know,
relatively speaking, they were.
Nobody can argue with.
That's quite clear at this point that.
The American people, if they want something
new, they don't want more of the same.
My worry is that Biden, who you know, people
will look at Biden and go, well.
I would rather give it another full year,
as ridiculous as that may seem.
Some people actually say that, you know, so
here's here's my father.
My understand what's wrong.
I understand what you're saying.
Here's why I disagree with it.
Number one, Donald Trump is such a different
political animal than anything we've had before.
And remember, Obama was it was a new U.S.
senator.
But he was a U.S. senator.
He was not, you know, some privileged real
estate dude from from New York City.
So.
So Trump is in a league of his own.
I believe that.
Listen, we'll see what happens in November.
I believe that Joe Biden has a reasonable
shot at winning.
We don't know what will happen because, you
know, Donald Trump has been so outrageous
that people are looking for a return to something
more familiar.
Now, that's not a defense of centrist politics.
And I hope that Joe Biden, if he wins, you
know, we have to do everything we can to pull
him to the left in every opportunity.
But I actually think that the
circumstances are so unique that going back
to something that feels more normal is exactly
what a lot of people want.
Yeah, and just just to add, just I just hope
hope to to well, I don't believe in God, but
hope to whatever that's come.
Twenty twenty twenty one.
The Senate, hopefully.
I know how you see that happening, but the
Senate somehow just finds a way to become
blue, hopefully.
Yeah.
I've done a bunch of analysis on that so I
won't go over the details.
But it's certainly it's possible.
It's a battle, but it's.
But it's possible.
Listen, I really appreciate the call from
Scotland.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Take care.
Hope to hear from you again.